ladies and gentlemen I think Joe Biden
may be not long for this world and it
breaks my heart it breaks my heart
um look we know the guy's 80 and these
photos have emerged showing strange
markings on his face
the guy is 80. we know he's got health
issues he's already passed the life
expectancy for the average U.S male I
think it's like 79 years old this he's
80 now I believe right
so these images pop up showing these
marks on his face and of course every
everyone is concerned as to what this
may be the media is reporting that he is
now using a CPAP machine because he
suffers from sleep apnea I believe
they're lying I believe what's more
likely is that he's an old man he's
probably on oxygen they're probably
supplementing him and they use they're
probably using these bands as a way to
obfuscate what's actually going on with
his ailing with his failing body they
claimed that his his gaffes speech
impediment no he doesn't have one he's
never you listen to him talking in the
90s he was speaking just fine
then they say Obama was younger he did
and that is now that he's getting older
it's coming back no he's just he's
getting older that's just it sure it's
fine call whatever you want it's still
because of age right the argument
they're making is oh he's getting older
so now it's coming back well yeah the
point of making a comment about the
stutter is because of his age that's
that's ridiculous but take a look at
this I mean he's got these these
markings on both sides of his face and
you know look
how long do those markings stay pressed
into his face did he did he wake up
literally right before he went out for
his flight took off the mask and had the
marks on his face the dude is is unwell
so in speaking about whether or not he
can run in 2024 I don't think there's a
question he can't yeah no he really
can't well and I think your strongest
case for the oxygen argument is that
it's almost it almost looks like any
moment he's not in front of people he
has to have something strapped he's got
he's got IV marks on his hands at one
point exactly and I'll stress this they
mentioned that uh let me let me pull up
the caption
his sleep apnea has been public
knowledge since 2008. and he wasn't
using a CPAP machine only now he is I
don't buy it no no also people go sleep
apnea wear it while they're sleeping
from what I understand not while they're
just sitting at their desk in their
office yes well this is a picture from
him in the morning about to get on some
plane but the question is did he just
wake up he's wearing a suit how long did
it take him to put that suit on and how
long would those markings stay on your
face I can't I can't imagine they'd
stand his face that long his suit
actually goes on like the Iron Man suit
just stand him up and the stuff just
gets thrown on him yeah I mean part of
what's happening with Biden I have
always found it annoying that the
mainstream media treats it like it's
super normal that he spends basically
all of his weekends at one of his two
private residences uh and that the White
House made this big shot of being like
we're so transparent here are the White
House visitor logs but we don't know who
goes to his house in Delaware you can
make an argument privacy should he be
allowed to whatever but it seemed clear
to me and again this is my personal
speculation that he is receiving
receiving some kind of medical treatment
when he goes home to Delaware on the
weekends because he was always I mean
even if he wasn't full on sick he's
always been getting older I mean he was
the oldest person elected president and
this has only continued to be true as he
has aged uh it seems like maybe things
are getting worse I it's hard to tell uh
but it feels to me like we're getting
more and more gaps now we're seeing
these markings it's only a matter of
time and I mean it's a good bet it's a
good bet and for me I kept saying when
is he going to announce that he's
running for reelection because his press
secretary seem to be hesitant even when
he was saying yes I will run and I think
that should tell you that the people
around him don't think he should
continue forward even if he himself
feels like there's no problem and maybe
he's not in a position to make that call
no I don't think he is here was the
other story from around the same time
they say uh president 80 says Putin is
clearly losing the war in Iraq while
clutching notes on Wagner Uprising and
yet another blunder yet another blunder
and look in this story you can see the
marks on his face cheat sheet
this dude can't handle it man
he never could handle it
no and at this point too it's it's
really frustrating because
I remember when they used to say Trump
goes to Mar-A-Lago too much or it golfs
too much I should say and uh they
criticized DeSantis for being on
potentially ozempic and RFK Juniors on
testosterone and so all the things that
we should all be talking about with
Biden he gets a free pass he gets a free
pass to potentially be using drugs that
keep him awake at day he gets a free
pass to not medically disclose to us
what he's actually doing that's keeping
him alive and somewhat sentient he
doesn't get criticized for going to
Delaware every seeming weekend he he
vacations more than any president we've
had in the last 40 years and he gets a
free pass for all of it so it's really
frustrating because it just feels like
we're all ignoring this massive elephant
in the room we're not obviously but a
lot of the country is and my greatest
fear that would cause me to really be
disappointed in our country and its
current state would be that if he
actually does run again and were to
somehow get reelected I think it would
be a massive indictment of our country
my biggest problem with what you're with
I I'm in agreement with you but my
biggest problem is the fact fact that
the American people I think are
generally aware of Biden's problems the
at least people that that actually are
politically aware that pay attention and
to you know enough to vote and stuff and
their ex they accept the obvious fact
that it is not the president that's
making the calls that means it is
someone else or it is a group of people
it's probably you know his advisors that
get together and make a you know make a
decision and tell him well Mr President
we're gonna do this because blah blah
blah and the fact that the American
people are comfortable with that to me
is a problem yeah we've gotten so
comfortable with the bureaucratic state
that we just don't even expect the
president to lead anymore and the one of
the biggest problems is that you don't
ever have anyone that's accountable when
the Situation's like this if there's
multiple bureaucrats that are making
decisions at the end of the day really
the ones making the decisions they will
never ever pay for any bad decisions
they will stay in office a lot of the
people that are still in the in the
Biden Administration are people that
were in the administration of George
Bush when we went into Iraq a lot of the
same players are still in Washington DC
in the you know in the quote-unquote
Deep state so you're not going to get
any kind of significant change until you
address that problem yeah well I think
it's another sign of that is that there
used to be a day in geopolitical
environments when like if you had a
president that had a gaffe like this
about major geopolitical actors like the
world would stand on notice because oh
my gosh the president of the Free World
just said something that about another
political leader related to war like
everybody used to really pay attention
and care and now it's like even the
other foreign leaders are like oh it's
another Tuesday with a gaffe and we
could call for war and no one would even
really do seriously we brought this up
when he was talking about Syria but kept
saying Libya yeah exactly and he kept
saying Libby over and over again and the
media of course downplayed saying oh
it's no big deal it is a big deal if he
goes to his generals and says I want to
see some territorial gains in Libya and
they go you got it next thing you know
it's like why is there a no-fly zone in
Libya it's like well Biden made a
mistake so what are the generals
supposed to do defy his orders this is
the this is this is the conundrum yes we
know he's not well in the in in the mind
and he's he said the wrong word I think
the average person can assume he did not
mean Libya
is it what if he did yeah are the
generals going to be like sir are you
sure and he's like yeah you know of
course come on man you know I'm talking
about okay or do they just say no he's
he's incapacitated so we're going to
defy his orders and ignore him well that
goes back to your point it's like I
don't even know who's in charge of the
generals at this point yeah how do they
make decisions you really think they ask
him for military strategy who knows like
no way I think it was Andy card I think
is his is his chief of staff or
something like that I'm not sure the
chief of staff but that it may be just a
name that I'm remembering but I'm sure
that it's not Joe Biden yeah you know
it's just it's it's a council or I'm not
one of the guys that thinks that you
know Barack Obama's running stuff from
behind the scenes there are people that
make those kind of remarks I don't think
that's the situation I think it's just
people that are high up in the in the
administration that are the bureaucratic
you know I I think it's Joe Biden and I
think Afghanistan is proof you think
it's him you think he's making look at
Afghanistan any any sane person who sat
down you could take your average
middle-aged overweight American Dad sit
him down in the situation room and say
Here's Afghanistan
we want to get out and that person would
do a better job that's true that's a
good point so so I I wonder if like the
abandoning Bagram Air Force Base not
notifying the Afghan Afghani Security
Forces everything they did every error
it was insane how bad it was it was pure
chaos so it could be that there is no
leadership at all so people were doing
random things but considering the they
that the US abandoned that we the U.S
abandoned the Bagram Air Force Base
I kind of feel like that was a
leadership call from someone who is not
right in the head
Joe Biden and we got we got to get our
troops out of there man you know not not
September we're gonna
go okay well where should we draw get
them out of the air just get them out
get him out Air Force Base get them out
okay withdraw them by the anniversary of
September 11th right he made it in an
emotional place instead of following a
tactical argument I'm shocked if he if
he was that uh that that Hands-On with
with how the with how do you explain it
I I don't have a better explanation but
I would be very surprised if President
Joe Biden was that Hands-On about how to
carry out the withdrawal because the you
know I too agree that it was ridiculous
to have the you know the combat troops
come out before the civilians absolutely
and abandoning the Air Force yes where
are you leaving all of our gear yeah
where you could get them out yeah I am
why I'm out of the Air Force Base I am
as
flabbergasted as you guys are that that
was the actual process that went that
actually happened I just would be really
surprised if Joe Biden was was you know
that granular about about commanding but
that's the point he wasn't
he's like hey we're gonna get our troops
out of there and it's like well look Mr
President we've got an Air Force Base we
can't just get him out of the Air Force
Base then are you sure yeah like oh
whatever you say sir and I always wonder
if the generals that received those
orders are also as incompetent or
nefarial come on like Millie exactly
that's where it's like I don't I I
wonder if it's literally just a comedy
of errors across the entire leadership
of the US government our intelligence
sucks if you were naive enough to
believe that Afghani officials and
forces there could hold that region and
that it fell in a matter of days like
how do you get things that wrong across
an entire organization as large and
profound as the US Military
it's a comedy bears and I always
struggle with how much do you attribute
to malicious intent versus incompetence
that is always a tough thing for me but
sometimes it's both yeah I think in this
case it was and I think in most things
happening in our government right now
there's a small faction of people that
are genuinely evil and then the rest of
the the people in The Nut House are just
pure incompetence at the highest degree
it's the people to judge that have no
ability or uh resume to lead
Transportation mayor of a nothing town
in in Indiana doing wrong South Bend's
fine but like what what do you even have
public transportation and you're leading
this like our whole government in the
bureaucratic State at this point is this
massive hodgepodge uh collaboration
between malicious intent evil actors and
incompetence at the highest level and
ultimately I think that's why like
anybody that's even remotely normal and
is able to present any sort of sense of
leadership is rising to the top of the
cultural conversation thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time